[Musik]
tatort deutschland die crime doku von
bild
wir befinden uns in trage bei hamburg
ein beschaulicher ort eine elbe an einem
schönen sommertag am deich stand stellt
eine vorbei radelnde dreiköpfige familie
ihre fahrräder und breitet eine geblümte
picknickdecke aus die mutter eine
hübsche blonde frau mit kurzen bob und
bonnie umarmt ihre kleine tochter der
vater ein sympathisch wirkender mann
mittleren alters holt die picknickkörbe
von den fahrrädern und setzt sich zu den
beiden auf die theke
das kleine mädchen wirft ihre langen
glatten haare zurück und umarmt auch
ihren vater dieser holt seine frau dazu
um den moment mit ihr zu teilen er
schaut sich voller liebe mit seinen
leuchtend blauen augen an ein schönes
bild nicht wahr und jetzt stellt euch
vor dass diese familie von dem einen auf
den anderen tag spurlos verschwindet die
leiche des mannes wurde mit hilfe eines
betonklotzes versenkt die mutter und
ihre tochter sind spurlos verschwunden
mein name ist sky dumont und ich begrüße
euch zu einer neuen ausgabe von tatort
deutschland
mit einem fall der nicht gelöst wurde
einem cold case was ist hier passiert
bild chefreporter thomas knoop betreut
den fall der familie schulze seit über
sechs jahren für bild berichte über 20
jahren über die kriminalfälle die hier
in norddeutschland oder ganz deutschland
passieren das ist jetzt schon ganz
besonderes für mich der lässt einen auch
persönlich einfach nicht wo ist
natürlich hat man einfach nur 1 1 ein
ziel am ende das der fall sagen ganz
familie von einem tag auch andere
stunden es ein verlust kurz nach dem
verbrechen im juli 2015 ist der fall top
thema in der bild-redaktion hamburg
bundesweit sorgt das tragische geschehen
für aufsehen
wo ist familie schulze von dieser brücke
sprang ein vater in den tod hier suchen
sie ihre leichen
hat jemand tatsächlich eine gesamte
familie ermordet hat der familienvater
selbst entschieden seine familie
auszulöschen und sich dann selbst zu
töten bis heute gibt der fall schulze
auch den ermittlern rätsel auf alle
spuren führen ins nichts alle hinweise
sind abgearbeitet
doch wie kann es sein dass menschen
einfach spurlos verschwinden
[Musik]
die schulzes sind eine kleine familie
die ein ruhiges leben in einem vorort
bei hamburg lebt das paar bestehend aus
markus silvia hat eine kleine tochter
die damals zwölfjährige merian ein
absolutes wunschkind halb schwester
sabine die us tochter aus einer früheren
beziehung beobachtet ein sehr inniges
verhältnis zwischen vater und tochter
mirjam liebt tiere besonders pferde
haben es ihr angetan
sie träumt er von tierpflegerin zu
werden und reitferien zu machen doch
dieser traum bleibt unerfüllt denn
miriam und ihre mutter silvia werden
seit dem 23
juli 2015 vermisst bild reporter thomas
knoop steht mit polizeihauptkommissar
jan krüger an dem gleich strand in frage
leichter nieselregen fällt vom himmel
der reporter schließt seine dunkelblaue
regenjacke
während jan krüger seine brille zurecht
rückt wenn so ein fall offen bleibt dann
hängt das an den kolleginnen und
kollegen letztendlich ist dass das was
für alle seiten total frustrierend und
nervenaufreibend ist dass wir so wenig
wissen über den konkreten ablauf und das
wir vor allen dingen
das definitiver ende nämlich das
auffinden von mutter und tochter nichts
haben so dass das immer noch
ungeklärt ist die einzige die von der
familie noch übrig ist ist halb
schwester sabine zucker thomas knoop
trifft die heute 30-jährige und läuft
mit ihr einen waldweg entlang sabine ist
damals bereits mit 16 jahren ausgezogen
heute hat sie ihre eigene familie der
schmerz des verlustes ist der blonden
frau die große ähnlichkeit mit ihrer
kleinen halbschwester hat deutlich
anzusehen um mit der schwierigen
situation klarzukommen schickt sabine
ihrer mutter bis heute sms so kann sie
mit dieser zumindest einseitig
kommunizieren und den verlust
verarbeiten
[Musik]
sabine verliert an nur einem tag ihre
mutter und ihre halbschwester ein
schwerer schicksalsschlag für die junge
frau gerade für die kleine miriam hätte
sie sich etwas anderes gewünscht
da wünsche ich mir manchmal halt einfach
hätte er sie einfach irgendwie mit einem
koffer von meiner tür abgestellt doch
was ist am tag des verbrechens passiert
will silvia sich vielleicht von ihrem
mann trennen woraufhin dieser ausrastet
oder steckt eine ganz andere erklärung
dahinter
aber von vorn es ist mittwoch der 22
juli 2015 ein tag vor den sommerferien
miriam ist krank und sie bleibt zu hause
wo ihr vater sich um sie kümmert während
silvia sich auf den weg zur arbeit bei
einem discounter in geesthacht macht am
nachmittag ruft der mann sie an da es
mir nicht gut geht silvia verlässt gegen
16 uhr vorzeitig ihre arbeitsstelle um
16.50 verbindet sich ihr handy mit dem
heimischen wlan netz danach gibt es von
silver schulze kein lebenszeichen keine
nachweisbare spur mehr gegen 17 uhr 25
telefoniert marco schulze noch von zu
hause mit dem besitzer eines reiterhofs
auf dem er gelegentlich aushilft er wird
für den nächsten tag angefragt doch
marco schulze zögert berichtet sein chef
später der polizei
was danach geschehen ist bleibt unklar
um 19 uhr 30 ruft markus schulze seinen
schwiegervater an erzählt dass es miriam
und seiner frau nicht gut geht und sich
beide schlafen gelegt hätten zeugen
beobachten an diesem abend noch wie
markus schulze mülltonnen vor die tür
seines hauses stellt doch fast in diesen
zwei stunden zwischen den beiden anrufen
passiert hat marco seine frau und sein
kind auf grausame weise ermordet
hauptkommissar jan krüger über die
letzten beobachtungen was sich
tatsächlich am späten nachmittag
beziehungsweise durch die ganze nacht
hindurch ereignet hat müssen wir bis
heute nicht es gibt eine weitere zeugen
die den familienvater noch am
donnerstagmorgen
ein name auto in drage wiederum gesehen
haben will mir dort vorbei fuhr danach
verliert sich die spur am nächsten tag
gehen die ersten vermisstenmeldungen 1
silvia ist nicht zur arbeit erschienen
und als die polizei das haus der familie
schulze durchsucht finden sie dieses
leer vor es deutete nichts auf
beispielsweise eine auseinandersetzung
in einen kampf der da stattgefunden
haben könnte es deutet nichts darauf hin
dass die familie möglicherweise verreist
war und wie man bescheid gesagt hat das
war eben in der summe so dass die
kollegen gesagt haben hier ist mir
passiert als einfach nur ein spontaner
wochenendtrip wir müssen hier weitere
maßnahmen treffen
obwohl ich weiß worauf du hinaus das
dorf sex oder sagen wir man hätte du
saufen sex in der öffentlichkeit was
bitte aufgerufen das siebzehnte
bundesland der mallorca podcast mit ingo
wohlfeil und stefan netzeband wie fühlt
sich der ballermann in der neuen saison
was kosten aktuell flüge und hotels
welche promis sind auf der insel und
welche stars den bierkönig oder mega
park mit das siebzehnte bundesland bist
du immer auf dem laufenden jeden
donnerstag wo es gute podcast gibt
[Musik]
eine riesige suchaktion beginnt die
polizei geht von einem unglück aus jeder
in der umgebung fragt sich wo ist
familie schuld sehen auch bild-reporter
knop ist damals bereits mit dem fall
vertraut und kann sich dieses einfach
nicht erklären in der hamburger
redaktion scrollt er durch die artikel
von damals als man mit den nachbarn
gesprochen hat und die alle sachen die
familie gilt als super zuverlässig und
auf einmal
da hatte man so das erste mal das gespür
da muss irgendwas passiert sein die
polizei und die feuerwehr besuchen die
umgebung und die gewässer um den prager
strand ab eine beliebte badestelle an
der elbe hauptkommissar krüger ist mit
dem bild journalisten vor ort er
erinnert sich noch genau an die
aufwendige aktion wir waren so nah mode
immer einsatztaucher haben hier den
bereich abgesucht um die ganzen linken
immer in der annahme möglicherweise weil
dieser ort doch irgendwo eine rolle
spielte im leben dieser familie das hier
mutter und tochter zu finden sind es ist
der 31 juli 2015 lauenburg an der elbe
eine anwohnerin macht an dem morgen eine
grausame entdeckung eine leiche treibt
durch das wasser sofort wird die polizei
alarmiert und auch reporter knop ist am
ort des geschehens ermittlung und so
sich über stunden hin und der ist kurz
vor mitternacht war
der leichnam von marco schulze laut
obduktionsbericht ist der todeszeitpunkt
die nacht vom 23
auf den 24 juli doch die umstände unter
denen die leiche aufgefunden wird sind
äußerst seltsam wie hauptkommissar
krüger erklärt beispielsweise war der
leichnam mit einem spanngurt
umwickelt an dem einen einen betonfuß
und letztendlich konnten wir dann im
zuge der weiteren ermittlungen
feststellen dass dieser betonfuß von
einer baustelle genommen worden war wir
haben dann natürlich umfangreiche
suchmaßnahmen in der elbe an der brücke
unter wasser am wasser durchgeführt
dabei konnte ein fahrrad am grund der
elbe aufgefunden werden auf dem fahrrad
selber waren noch spannend wurde
gleicher bauart wie sie auch am körper
befestigt waren zu finden und das
fahrrad konnte letztendlich auch der
familie zugeordnet werden sabine zenker
wird damals sofort benachrichtigt
wirklich auf so eine art und weise das
leben zu nehmen zeigt für mich
eigentlich irgendwie davon dass er sich
dann auch für irgendwas strafen heute
hat marco schulze wirklich seine frau
und seine tochter auf dem gewissen
sabine beteuert von spannungen in der
ehe ihrer mutter gewusst zu haben
dass sie sich trennen wollte und
er das nicht akzeptieren wollte oder
konnte und dann halt natürlich auch
irgendwie angst hatte sanken zu
verlieren vielleicht war er nicht
besonders belastbar und hat das alles
genommen und sich alles so zu herzen
genommen dass er dadurch so belastet war
dass er keinen anderen ausweg mehr sah
einige wochen nach dem verschwinden dann
endlich die erste spur eine zeugen
meldet sich zu wort sie will die familie
noch am nachmittag des 22
juli 2015 also am tag des verschwindens
gesehen haben und zwar am teilchen holm
seppensen pensen circa 50 kilometer von
trage entfernt ihren aussagen nach
steigt sich die familie später sind
schreie zu hören und am ende gibt es
sogar eine art knall
thomas knoop und jan krüger stehen an
der begrünten stelle am besagten teich
eine ruhige unauffällige gegend hat hier
ein schrecklicher streit stattgefunden
der mit einer bluttat endete
im zuge der überprüfung dort auch
tatsächlich
geruchsspuren durch mehrere
fährtensuchhunde
anzeigen lassen können die übereinstimmt
die fährte von vater mutter und tochter
angezeigt haben die spuren von mutter
und tochter endeten am see und nur die
spur des vaters wurde um den see herum
bis zur straße zurück angezeigt der see
ist fünf meter tief als mann hat mehrere
punkte markiert es war der in 17
insgesamt gibt sind mit dem solarboot
ausfindig gemacht worden bei jedem kind
dachte man jetzt passiert was jetzt
kommt eine entdeckung es passiert am
ende nicht obwohl also spuren der
familie gefunden werden ergibt diese
beobachtung kein stimmiges bild schwer
vorstellbar dass vater marco schulze in
dieser frei zugänglichen spazier gegend
weil eben einen doppelmord begeht zumal
er wegen der entfernung zwischen trage
und dem mühlenteich in holm seppensen
nur 30 minuten gehabt hätte um mutter
und tochter zu töten und die leiche
verschwinden zu lassen und wie passen
die telefonate in den ablauf die schulze
ja nachweislich mit chef und
schwiegervater geführt hat auch thomas
knoop und jan krüger zweifel an dieser
these der vater ist ja kein profi killer
oder ähnliches sondern ein familienvater
erzählte hat er seine tochter über alles
geliebt warum er dann das vermeintlich
perfekte verbrechen begangen haben
könnte
erschließt sich mir überhaupt gar nicht
letztendlich ist dass das was für alle
seiten total frustrierend und
nervenaufreibend ist dass wir so wenig
wissen über den konkreten ablauf und das
wir vor allen dingen
das definitiven ende nämlich das
auffinden von mutter und tochter nicht
haben so dass das immer noch
ungeklärt ist die ermittlungen in dem
fall schulze sind mittlerweile
abgeschlossen eine lösung gibt es nicht
der fall wird zum cold case was die
beteiligten und vor allem die letzte
familienangehörige sabine sehr belastet
ich hoffe tatsächlich dass sie gefunden
werden auf welche art auch in mainz wird
mir klarheit bringen und klarheit ist
heilung irgendwann und heilung bedeutet
für mich dass ich abschließen kann die
polizei gibt jedoch nicht auf und wendet
sich erneut mit einem appell an die
öffentlichkeit bis heute sucht die
polizei weitere zeugen die
möglicherweise die familie oder auch nur
den familienvater in der nacht vom 22
auf den 23 juli 2015 oder sogar in der
nacht vom 23 auf den 24 juli 2015
gesehen haben wir wissen nicht genau zu
welchem zeitpunkt der familienvater sich
mit dem fahrrad von trage nach lauenburg
an der elbe bewegt hat um dort
selbstmord zu begehen alle beteiligten
ermittler setzen auf hinweise aus der
bevölkerung
bleibt bis zum schluss dran es gibt noch
wichtige informationen an dieser stelle
verabschiede ich mich von euch bis zum
nächsten mal das kino
am 22 juli hört man zum letzten mal von
der im niedersächsischen drage an der
elbe lebenden silvia und ihrer
zwölfjährigen tochter miriam wenn sie
etwas ungewöhnliches zu der zeit vom 22
bis zum 24 juli 2015 bemerkt haben oder
etwas genaueres wissen was den
ermittlern helfen könnte dann zögern sie
nicht lange das schicksal von silvia und
miriam verdient nach sechs langen jahren
endlich klarheit und sabine zenker eine
zurückgelassene tochter und schwester
somit eine chance auf gewissheit melden
sie sich bei der polizeiinspektion
harburg unter der rufnummer 04181
tatort deutschland ist eine produktion
aus dem wakeboard studios
projektleitung simone der bank
produktion fabian schaeffler drehbuch
nadja goldhammer redaktion bild thomas
knoop und stefan netzeband
[Musik]
mein name ist frank schneider ich bin
chefreporter bei bild und seit 29 jahren
polizeireporter im eiskalt to cry
marathon bitte in unser reporter sich
großen kriminalfällen die auch mich
besonders schockierend bis heute nicht
loslassen verschwundene kinder grausame
leichenfunde ungewöhnliche tatwaffen
oder brutale arten einen mord zu
vertuschen in insgesamt acht folgen
gehen wir zurück an die tatorte
gesprächen mit betroffenen opfern und
sogar tätern und präsentieren den
aktuellen stand der ermittlungen
eiskalt die größten kriminalfälle der
neue true crime marathon bei bild tv am
18 august ab 20 15 und im anschluss alle
folgen in der bild mediathek für bild +
alle infos zu bild im tv finden sie auch
unter bild.de
[Musik]